thank you very much uh for joining i'll
just give a very brief introduction here
uh so karsh will be sharing his work on
python and and flutter uh in the
application of coloring enhancing old
photos
um a little bit of a background it i see
from your uh web page that you're an
inspiring and all researcher but it
looks like you actually are a ml
researcher so you might want to update
that looks great looking forward to your
session so please go ahead okay thank
you so i will be starting
uh
so my talk
the title of my talk is python and
clutter applications for coloring and
enhancing old photos and in the stock i
would be like uh i just developed a
product
in using flutter application and i use
the python
i use python libraries to make to
convert those old and black and white
images to colored ones and as these
softwares are like uh
most of the times even if we get these
stamps kinds of software we have like
they are
kind of costly right so i try to provide
it in a free way and even in
usable manner like most of the people
use applications or
what can i say mobile apps right
so from
so i developed a product
using flutter it's through a mobile
android mobile application through which
anyone can upload a photo and they can
get a colored photo and return
okay so i would just be
so about me i am a recent graduate and a
machine learning developer at queer
infotech
it's a rpa based company in india
and my major technical skills are in the
field of machine learning deep learning
and
those flood wrap development and those
data analytics okay
so basically what like uh
first of all the first question arises
here is what are photos
so basically the photo uh some kind of
images in computer science we
think of them as images
and i can express them as like some kind
of an external form
or a person from the past like we
generally capture photos to remember
someone or some kind of special moment
from the past right it kind of
communicates some past incidents to us
so then what are black and white photos
especially these black and white photos
like more
before these colored photos we have
black and white photos right and those
black and white photos we only have a
single gray color channel
and i sometimes feel like they are like
less realistic and like they
have they
have
subtleness in them but like
they don't express reality in
better form
than
color ones right
so
in traditional manners
these images
these black and white images can be
converted to other ones first is
the
most used
most used manner by hand and secondly we
can use computers for that using adobe
photoshop
but in both these manners we
do them
by
like we require manual intervention
right
so the most important question that
arises just now is why do we need
machine learning for this stuff we
already have two ways to do
the same thing why do we need machine
learning for that
so we need machine learning because
these processes are time consuming even
if we
do the same thing by hand or by adobe
photoshop we require a lot of time and
it's also requires some personal
intervention or like we can
use the same thing
so basically by the machine learning we
can just reduce the image coloring to a
matter of seconds or minutes okay so
basically i just provided a api
flowchart i just used a flask api for
the thing for correcting it with
flutter application and this is
api flowchart
so i will just be starting
by giving introduction related to the
examples and the fields that i have used
in building the product
so first of all
a difference
i would be telling you about deep
learning so
the difference between an ai ml and
deep learning so basically the ai is for
the computers uh in ai we try computers
uh maybe try to make computers so that
they can mimic human or brain activities
we in ai we try to create a complete
human most of the time
right
but uh whereas in machine learning ai is
kind of a we can say ai generally
consists of
conceptual things not practical
implementation so in machine learning
it's kind of a subset for ai only we try
to create some techniques or like some
methods mathematical calculations
programs so that we can so that a
computer
can
compute some things and can classify or
can try again mimic human activities
okay so what is the difference then
what's the difference between ai sorry
machine learning and deep learning so
mainly deep learning is kind of a subset
of machine learning right so in machine
in deep learning we
generally deals with non-structured kind
of data so unstructured kind of data
unstructured means related to images
audios
uh speech text those kinds of data so we
try to compute or
solve more complex forms of data
with the help of deep learning
so next is our cnn
okay so
it's cnn convolutional numerator we can
also call it connect
they
are mostly used for analyzing images or
we can say we can also analyze audio
tech audio data text data using the
spectral uh
spectrograms
okay so basically we try to extract
feature maps or data from the images
by
performing some sequence of convolutions
or cooling operations
so first of all in the images concept
that we come across a term called as
kernels so basically kernels are kind of
small filters we can call them
convolutional matrix filters okay so
they are basically used for blurring out
sharpening and processing like we can
say image processing techniques
so
they do all these things these kernels
we perform some uh operation called as
convolution operation
to
uh to find the blurriness the sharpness
embrasment edge detection and those
kinds of stuffs
so the next thing is like there
we have generally two kinds of
operations in
cnn it's called convolution and cooling
basically we have these two kinds of
layers convolution layer and a pulling
layer okay
so basically i
have also added an example
for
uh to write the the code of convolution
layer and the max pooling layer
in tensorflow so first of all
what is a convolutional operation so
basically a convolution is kind of a
simple filter
uh it tries to
it
i would say
it basically tries to multiply the
individual elements with their filter
with the individual elements of the
filter and then sum them up to create
somewhere to extract some kind of data
from it
so basically by applying convolution
operation again and again to the same
same image by using same kind of filter
only different kinds of filter we can
extract some
important features from that image we
can we can also call that output or that
features
as feature maps
so
this is an example of how can we use
the convolution layer intense flow
basically use
i just gave an example from keras
so the kera
that example the keras uses tends flow
as back end so in keras there is a class
called as
layer
and that class layers we have a
no oh sorry and there is a
sub file called as layer and that's a
file we have a class known as column2d
so that in the con 2d we can perform
these
operations first is the number of
filters second is the first parameters
the number of filters second parameter
is the size size of the kernel
so in this example we have given the
size as three comma three right and the
padding there are
many different operations
and the max pooling
max pooling is kind of uh we can say
maximum is kind of a down sampling of
the feature map
so
we tries to reduce the size of the image
by
the
sorry
by reducing the size of the image we can
reduce
the number of parameters as well as we
can extract
the
important feature maps not
the irregular ones
so basically the
pooling operations we have there are two
kinds of cooling is max pooling and an
average cooling
so in the
pooling operation also we have the same
things from keras on layers dot
average cooling 2d and max bluetooth
so i have also
use an add layer add layer generators
add layer
just add two
matrices of same size
okay so next is and one concept of an
auto encoder so
an auto encoder is
is a kind of an artificial neural
network you can say
which tries to
learn data
from
by compressing it
so
and auto encoder is basically consists
of three contains three parts
first is an encoder portion a decoder
portion and a bottleneck portion okay so
in the encoder portion we try is to
compress like compress or extract
features from the image in the bottom
left portion we
add some
[Music]
like full we can say fcnn
or
some dense layers and then in the
decoder portion we try to recreate that
same image
okay so basically it learns data by
compressing it in the encoder portion in
the bottom left portion it processes it
to extract
the important features or to learn it
and when the decoder portion tries to
recreate it
[Music]
next this is encode of an autoencoder
portion
sorry
okay so basically there are different
different types of autocoders like
denoising auto encoder sparse auto
encoder
deep water encoder
uh convolutional auto encoder variation
okay so in my project i just use
convolutional auto encoder because i am
like in this product we are like using
we are just
compressing the image a black and white
image
and then
trying to recreate a colored image
right so i have used convolutional auto
encoder
in that i have also used skip
connections
so
mostly uh
neural networks or the large neural
networks
suffer from a problem called as
degradation problem so in degradation
problem
uh whenever the depth of the network
increases
the
parameter the gradient parameters
becomes so small that this that even
multiplying or squaring them
gives
nominal or like i can say no changes
right
so
we
generally use skip connections this
concept was used in resonate
that was
given by microsoft
so basically with these auto encoders
uh
the convolutional automation
have convolutional and deconvolutionary
layers right
so they also suffer from the problem of
degradation
so most of the time when we like
decompress the image and then recreate
it
it may happen that the important
features or the information that image
can be like if and for if an image
contains a cloud or a tree that
information might get lost
so
oh
to improve that
uh i have used skip connection
and these kit connections are from a
convolutional layer to a deconvolutional
layer
or i would say from an encoder a part of
an encoder to the part of a decoder it's
skipping
over the bottleneck section
so i'm just sending the feature from a
convolutional section
to a deconvolution section so that even
if an information get lost it can be
created in the hardware layers
so
however i have come again to this api
flowchart so in the api filter i have
also used like i told you about the
model prediction thing
so my model like my model architecture
looks kind of similar to this because
this is a unit
a unit architecture
so i also use
i
so consecutively use three
convolution layers and then a max
pooling layer
to reduce the parameters and
just take the important parameters
into account
[Music]
in those in those convolution layers
also
the two subsequent layers are
like have exactly the same things as
even the padding are same so the image
is not even the decide like it's not
even
like the image size does not even change
in the next layer i've increased the
number of filters so that even after two
conver after full configuration the
number of filter the number of
important feature maps we have
might
increase
to the in the third layer so that we can
get
the features in depth
so that was an encoder section
this is the decoder section where i try
to like up sample the images and
recreate it
so first i have used the up sampling one
so i have increased the image like image
size
by up sampling it then i have used that
skip connection
and in the skip connection i have used
the add layer so
the
layer
so the
feature map from the convolutional uh
from the encoder section
is transferred to the decoder section
and is being added so that the features
can be retained then i use like two or
three convolution layers yes and then
this function has been repeated again
and again that after these three
convolutional layers the up sampling is
being called again
then the same add function
of the skip connection
and then three convolution end up
sampling and the same process happens
again and again
so i've used two other functionalities
in the api there's a like comma
connection and a super image resolution
so i have used in a gamma collection
here so most of the times when we give
some kind of images we
might encounter images that are like
very dark right so to reduce the image
darkness i've used gamma collection
so gamma correction tries to control the
brightness overall brightness of the
image okay so by varying the amount of
gamma uh we can change the brightness
of the image
and we can also save it
changes the ratio or the color ratios of
the three images like uh
the
color ratios of rgb channel
this is an example of gamma correction
code
next in the flow chart i've used super
image resolution also because
most of the time the older images that
we
even easily click or we have unlike
small very small images like 200 to 200
pixels so
those photos might if you want to like
if you want to use those photos
somewhere we might be requiring them to
have like around 2000 pixels right so
i've
i have also added the super image
resolution so that the model
can like so that the image that we
received from the model is of a high is
of a fixed level pixel so that even if
we have to use it somewhere else it
won't be a problem
so basically in the same super image
resolution like uh
the
these are like some some sets of
algorithms and techniques to increase
the size of the image or like up
sampling the image resolution up some
like the image or and also keeping the
resolution as same
so
if i let it
if i need to take like the image if
i put it more simply
uh
if we increase the image from its height
of it the
degradation in the image
one
uh there won't be any degradation in the
quality of the image
so the next is an api which is just
about an api so basically it's an api
it's kind of an intermediate software
that allows communication between two
applications
it kind of acts as a gateway that
allows these back-end softwares or
servers to communicate with them okay
so
most of the times we have this we use
these weather apps right so these
weather apps generally contains these
uh apis or
some other things
to
get us like weather even these
even we can say these apis are used to
like in the chatting applications and
facebook or like weather applications
instant messaging pms we can use apis
okay so there are different different
types of frameworks in python i only use
the flask one
so this is like a basic code for the
flask uh
like a small
hope where we need to like create an
object of the class flask
mask
and i have
given debug equals to false
that means uh even if we run the code if
if he changes the code if we even change
the code we have to run the server
this is one example next for the
production purpose i have used the
flutter application
so
it's like the most advantage there are
like many advantages of flutter so first
of all it's like it has beautiful it's
has beautiful ui it's productive it is
very fast and it's open source i would
just be experiencing one of those so
basically this flutter is an expressive
and has beautiful device it has many
built-in material apps designs even it
has cupid universe uh
i would say these computer devices are
used in ios applications
so it has motion rich apis and natural
scrolling and many other things
so
it has the production native native
performance
so
this uh so in the application uh
they're like in the application we have
a natural kind of scrolling we have
scrolling uh we have different kinds of
scrolling we have different kinds of
icons and fonts and navigations for
different different platforms
that's very fast
i would say very fast for development so
because flutter has two important things
called as hot reload and how to restart
like if i'm like developing an
application and i'm running my
application on my mobile device if i
even do some changes and if i just save
it
the
the changes would be shown in the
ui
in a matter of seconds even if you have
restarted all the changes even then
files and code or even there's a kind of
error those errors might be resolved in
how to restart it also helps like
it helps in quick implementation of ui
features and also helps in fixing the
box faster and the most important thing
just like flutter uh flutter is uh just
like python flutter is open source and
it's freely available and it's like
thousands of packages in python we have
packages right so in flutter we have
plugins
like there are thousands of plugins for
uis back-ends and other things
so
what kind of language
do we need so a pipe flutter basically
uses dart language and this language is
kind of similar to java
uh the platform availability most
important thing it's native
and
we can build a same python same python
code can be run for both android and ios
for wherever for creating websites the
same code can be used in
desktop here for i would not i would not
say desktop just the desktop i can say
all the three types of computer versions
like on the linux mac os or the windows
and recently it has stepped
in
embedded system also
so this is a small sample code for like
designing
there's a main class
the user and app function to call the
main class they're like themes uh
material app this material builds the
whole application
and we here we have a scroll uh
scaffold so the scaffold is like a
complete
first page like a complete page and a
complete page we have the app bar the
app bar is this top bar in the blue
color we have the welcome to flutter
written inside it and the center widget
so basically in the flutter we have
something spot as visits and they're
like state there are two kinds of states
like stateless and stateful there are
many different different concepts
so a small application demo
i'm just going to show it to you so this
is my application you can just select
images from camera or
from the
gallery you just have selected this is a
crop section if you want to take the
complete image and you want to drop it
drop it then there's a small
confirmation screen do you want to drop
it back like
or like you want to continue with images
to continue it this small loading uh
this is the most time taking process
because the image has been uploaded to
the api where the model processes
process the two or three steps and then
the image has been sent back and the
image is around like two
i would say more than 1000 pixels around
okay
so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much utkarsh uh so
do we have any questions sorry i'm just
looking now in the q a
uh so we have a question from eugenio so
just to clarify where the where does the
python code run
uh
i would the python code is running on
the
it's a flask api
so it's been deployed on the hero4
it's i would say it's running on a
remote server
mostly a linux space server
okay
great
any other questions for utkarsh
well i guess you covered everything in
your presentation that was really
interesting oh another question here is
the code available on github yes super
important
uh just now the code is not available on
the github like i have the all the code
is been available on the github but it's
private repository so
and it is also some kind of project my
personal project so i cannot just go on
and
give you all the code
and i'm like thinking about
uh changing
the
changing the
repository from private to public
it might be happening in like around one
or two months
let me see
because i am not the only one who has
worked on this project like they were
like one or two of my friends also i
need their
consideration
okay well we we certainly hope to uh see
more of that than in future and
hopefully open up that repo
well i think let's let's close up your
session now with karsh and if there's
any
additional questions uh you can take it
up with utkarsh over slack or other
names
so thank you very much thank you